[音楽]
danejones
まずはある音を聞いてもらいます
kan
何て言ってるか聞き取りづらかったと思います
続いて今度はこの聞き取りづらかった部分のノイズを省いた音をもう一度聞いて思い
ます
v 林美杏なおぬ
プレイ bing 子あのん日本語でわからないことから始めよう
これは聞き取れましたよね
では最後にもう一度聞き取りづらかった最初の音を聞いてもらいます
aname
なんて言ってるか聞こえたんじゃないでしょうか
これ何が言いたいかと言いますと同じ音でも来ての経験によって解釈が異なるという
ことなんですね
このことからちっと音楽とは聞き手のもそれぞれの解釈が加わった時初めて本当の完成
を迎えると言っても過言ではないと思います
つまりこれは聞くことがとても
創造的な声であると言えますそしてそれはもちろん音楽だけにとどまりません
作り手は時として必要以上に詰め込まれた音や情報
あえて間引いてきての自由な発想を引き出すための余地を確保します今日はこの予知に
おけるちょっと
不確かなものをこれが
一体何なのかについてお話をします
2017年あるプロジェクトを進めていました
その頃僕はいろんな街に赴きその街の音を作る仕事をしています
仕事というよりは毎日がほぼ旅のようなものでもありました
ひょんなことから日本を代表する温泉の町
大分県別府市の地域事業に携わることになります
音を作るのではなくて
で街づくりのプロジェクトだったんですね
遊園地計画と言います
温泉という延長を掛け合わせてイメージムービーを作ってその動画が100万再生を
達成するとそれを本当に実現してしまうという内容のものでした
動画は効果より3日後に早々に目標を達成し早速
遊園地を実現するために動き始めるわけですが
制作メンバーのほとんどがその町で暮らしていたわけでもなくその街に何があるのか
すら分からない
ましてや僕にとっては音楽すらそしない
誰がこの温泉遊園地をつくるのか
そんな不確かなよ血だらけのスタートでした
当時相当困っていたように見えたのかもしれません
何から手をつけてよいのかそれすらわからない
時間だけが過ぎていく中で僕たちは半ば開き直ってやれることをやろうと
まちを歩き人に声をかけ些細なことでも出会う人にこの街の魅力について教えを超え
ました
聞かないと何も始まらない思い切って対話をする
とってもシンプルなことをやっただけです
そんな僕たちを見かねて多くの人がいろんなことを教えてくれたんですね色んな場所に
も連れて行ってくれましたそしてこのことがきっかけでたくさんの地域の方が
このプロジェクトに参加することになっていくわけです
そしてその後地域の人たちが主役となる温泉雄一が完成します
その街の魅力と得意技を集結した約1200人ものおもてなし隊が活躍する
まさにおもてなしの街別府にしかできない
世界に一つだけの温泉遊園地だったと思います
当初温泉と遊園地を融合する計画に最後はそこに地域の人たちが掛け合わさって新しい
オリジナルとなりゴールを迎えたわけですこの結果は誰も想像すらできていなかったと
思います
そして何よりも素晴らしかったのはその体験をたくさん
の人たちと共有できたことです
不確かなことは非常に心もとないです
ただそれを受け入れ開放したときにその心の隙間を埋めるように誰かがやってきて
コンタクト取ろうとしますそこから生まれる
セッションのようなものが結果的には想像もしていなかった未来へと導いてくれる
そんな可能性があると
ということですとてもシンプルなことですが身を持って体験してしまった以上
改めてこれを多くの人に伝えたい僕は強く思いました
遊園地計画を経験して今僕が皆さんに言えることは
不確かを受け入れてぜひ大和の旅に出てみてはどうかということです
何も難しく考えることはありません
不確かはいつも僕たちの周りに溢れています
この答えがわからない
好きな人の今日の起源はどうだろうか
メロンパンの中にはなんでメロンが入っていないのか
些細なことでもそれを超えに音に出すことから始まります
人類は対話を積み重ね未来を切り拓いてきました2020年世界共通の課題によって
分断されより対話の必要性を痛感する
いうこととなってしまいました
オンラインでの開催となったこのテレックス福岡が皆さんとの新しい
対話のきっかけを作ってくれたことに大変感謝しています
音は目に見えません不確かなものです
だからこそ僕たちの何かを引き出す余地があります
最初に聴いてもらった音もまた改めて聞くと何か
未来への扉を開けてくれるようなそんな余地を確かに感じるはずです
dare
わからないから始めよう
[音楽]